[Musique]
Aud Lancelin. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit en tant que journaliste,
travaillant dans le média TV, ayant
travaillé dans quelques canards
importants. Comment ça va ?
Ça va très bien.
Ça va très bien. Depuis combien de temps
?
Euh depuis que j'ai quitté une certaine
presse.
Racontez-nous ça.
Et bien
je me retrouve maintenant dans un dans à
l'issue de toute une série d'événements
il est vrai difficile à travers et
violent. Je me retrouve dans un projet
particulier particulièrement intéressant
qui me correspond et où je gagne trois
fois moins mais où je suis beaucoup plus
heureuse.
C'est quoi gagner trois fois moins ?
Vous gagnez combien à l'heure actuelle
et vous avez gagné combien ailleurs ?
Ah, c'est comme ça ici.
Euh
disons que ça se joue entre 3000 et
9000.
Donc vous prenez 3000 en ce moment, vous
étiez à 9000 àOPS ?
Oui, c'est ce que je vous dis.
D'accord.
Ça vous fait quel effet euh de retourner
dans les sphères basses des salaires ?
Rien du tout à vrai dire. Euh euh je me
sens tellement plus en phase avec
moi-même, avec ce qui compte pour moi,
avec mes engagements,
que ça n'est même pas un sacrifice.
On va faire un petit résumé de vos
dernières affaires rapidement. Vous avez
travaillé 13 ans à l'OPS. Vous avez fini
vos deux dernières années comme
rédactrice adjointe en chef.
Euh vous avez subi un licenciement qui
pour vous a été qualifié de licenciement
politique.
Vous avez demandé un peu plus de 4500 €
à votre employeur et votre tribunal des
prudomes vous a donné 90 € et je crois
qu'il a fait appel
90 c'est c'est quand même très peu hein.
Désolé autant pour moi.
Euh vous vivez ça comment ?
Ah moi j'étais très heureuse parce
qu'ils ont été condamnés à pour
licenciement abusif, ce qui était
absolument l'essentiel dans cette
affaire pour moi. Euh après la la somme
évidemment euh c'est pas nous qui
l'avons fixé arbitrairement pour les
gens qui connaissent les prudomes. C'est
en fonction du des des dommages subis et
en l'occurrence de dommages d'images
considérables. tapez mon nom sur
internet, vous avez 250 articles avec le
mot licenciement, hein, et et toute une
presse m'est tombée dessus, aé ma vie
privée euh et et et m'a fait énormément
de tort. Donc c'est tout ça qui pèse au
prudom. Maintenant, je vous signale
Scoop pour Finkerview,
c'est que le il y a un appel, l'OPS a
fait appel contre moi, c'est-à-dire que
là, on est vraiment dans l'acharnement
euh judiciaire. Donc l'affaire sera
rejugée cette fois-ci par des magistrats
professionnels. Et je vais vous dire
tout de suite, c'est plutôt une bonne
chose sur moi pour moi parce que les
prudomes ne condamnent ne prononcent
jamais quasiment la nullité d'un
licenciement tandis qu'un des magistrats
professionnels avec le dossier embêtant
qu'on a le feront. Je n'ai aucun doute
là-dessus.
Vous avez décidé de switcher pour une
nouvelle aventure qui s'appelle le
média.
Comment ça se passe à l'heure actuelle
le média ?
C'est euh une aventure passionnante.
Euh, on est une petite équipe
extrêmement soudée
euh avec un combat absolument clair, une
meute en face de nous euh qui croit
pouvoir voilà nous nous effrayer, nous
faire du temps, mais qui ne fait euh
chaque jour qui passe que nous que nous
souder davantage.
Euh et
euh il se trouve qu'on a eu bon ben je
crois que c'est public euh quelques
turbulence euh depuis quelques jours euh
justifier un justifier
un départ euh bah justifié euh disons
que c'est instrumentalisé par notre par
la presse CAC 40, nos ennemis,
les gens que notre projet
menace ou
ils se sentent menacés. Pourquoi
alors ? Mais non mais il y a deux
catégories
selon votre intéressories
c'est qu'on est des nain à l'heure
actuelle. On est David contre Goliath
mais David peut gagner et surtout David
peut donner la parole à des voix
discordantes qui ne qui ne l'ont plus
jamais nulle part.
Comme qui ?
Et bien la personne que j'ai reçu hier
soir par exemple
Annie Lacroix. Yan la croiri n'a la
parole nulle part, nulle part à la
télévision, nulle part à la radio. Euh
et vous connaissez bien l'arme de
dissuasion massive
pour les gens qui ont un discours
hétérodoxe, quel que soit leur que ce
soit en économie, en philosophie ou et
bien c'est le complotisme, le
conspirationnisme,
voir le poutinisme, l'antisémitisme et
cetera. Donc euh Annie La Croiries est
victime de ça depuis des années. Je
prends cet exemple, je pourrais en
prendre 10 autres. Euh
Annie Laquaris d'une et issue d'une
famille juive euh communiste se voit euh
qui venait en l'occurrence au médias euh
pour euh commenter très durement la
vague de reparution d'auteur fasciste,
de rebatta au penflet de Céline en
passant par la commémoration nationale
avortée de Moras. et euh on n'écoute pas
ce qu'elle dit et on on l'accuse à
nouveau de bon voilà, on connaît le on
connaît le manège, on connaît le rayon
paralysant, on sait comment ça
fonctionne et nous nous avons ouvert un
canal où toutes ces choses-là pourront
être dites. Et puis il y a une autre
catégorie disais-je, c'est c'est aussi
les autres sites alternatifs, les autres
sites de gauche radical qui eux
réagissent en en boutiquier qui dont la
clientèle menace de fuir quoi. Voilà.
Donc en fait, on a vraiment tout le
monde contre nous. C'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre. On a absolument toute la
confréerie pourtant d'habitude toujours
pronte à se serrer les coudes. Euh
contre
des journalistes. Vous parlez des
journalistes ?
Oui. Moi, je reçois depuis 2 jours euh
des messages de fausse commissération,
euh des messages plus ou moins
menaçants, des
de qui ?
De confrère de
de qui ? Non. Non non, je peux pas faire
ça.
Bah c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment
désolant et dégueulasse. Moi je veux pas
les exhiber mais
c'est une forme de macartisme.
Ah oui non mais clairement ça moi je le
macartisme
sévit dans ce pays. Ça date pas d'hier
hein, c'est une longue histoire depuis
la fin des années 70. Euh c'est-à-dire
que euh la chasse au rouge
euh s'est mis en place en France au
tournant des années 80. Euh, elle est
d'une virulence extrême dans les milieux
intellectuels journalistique à force. Et
euh là, on arrive euh dans une phase de
tension maximale parce que peut-être
pour la première fois une force
politique
euh
remonte la tête et porte à nouveau
jusque dans l'assemblée
ce discours qui avait été délégitimé
entièrement. Donc ils sont très
inquiets. Ils sont très inquiets. En
plus leur leur nouveau
le président, le chouchou du Kante qui a
été porté à l'Élysée.
Euh euh contrairement à ce qu'on nous
raconte, ne on commence à se rendre
compte que la population n'est pas
séduite. On a déjà touché le fond au
niveau des sondages. On est déjà les
sondages au sondage les plus bas de
toute la 5e République.
Combien combien
là ? J'ai pas le chiffre en tête mais
c'est tombé il y a quelques jours et
jamais un président sous la 5e
République n'est descendu aussi bas.
Donc la situation est quand même
inquiétante puisqu'on a à la fois les
vagues de réformes les plus rapides et
violentes.
Les vagues de réforme néolibérales les
plus rapides et violentes qui est connu
notre pays et en même temps un
assentiment de la population qui est
plus que discutable. Donc il y a une
espèce d'étrange silence. Euh je pense
que le pouvoir surveille
le média en ce moment de ces audience
c'est comment ?
Euh je alors c'est compliqué parce que
on on fait un journal en direct tous les
jours, mais évidemment il y a beaucoup
de replay. Moi j'ai des émissions euh
qui sont avant tout regardées en podcast
en voilà après coup quoi. Euh je crois
je
bonne fourchette bonne fourchette.
Ouais, je veux pas je veux pas vous dire
de bêtises et vraiment c'est pas pour
vous cacher des trucs. Je crois que
l'audience en direct du journal en ce
moment est autour de 15000
20000.
Bon 20000 tant mieux.
Mais si vous voulez entre 20h le moment
de la diffusion en direct et minuit euh
il y a 40 40000 personnes qui l'ont vu.
Vous
Non, ça commence à 10000 et puis ça
finit à minuit à 20000. des fois 23 j'ai
franchement j'ai je vais vous dire la
vérité un pic de journal avec signeux
pour le premier qui était à 117000
oui mais ça c'est c'est pas honnêtement
c'est
c'est l'excitation de la première fois
c'est ça
évidemment mais il y a même même les
trolls les ennemis l'extrême droite qui
regardent voilà c'est comme quand on
lance une nouvelle formule avec un
journal hein vous commencez à à 150000
et puis voilà après il y a un étiage
normal qui s'instaure c'est ce qu'on vit
mais par exemple on a fait un live le
notre premier politique sur les réformes
de l'éducation en frontale avec France 2
et il y avait il y avait 40 dès le
premier soir, il y avait 40000
visionnages. Donc c'est des chiffres
pour
une web télé, pour une proposition
politique alternative. Tout à fait.
Pourquoi vous dites proposition
politique alternative ? On vous reproche
souvent d'être le média de Mélenchon.
Même arè sur image dit le média
insoumis.
même arrê surage.
On dit bonjour à Daniel.
Daniel,
si tu nous entends, viens faire du
sport. Euh,
c'est c'est vrai ? C'est pas vrai ? Vous
avez voté quoi aux dernières élections ?
Moi moi j'ai voté j'ai voté Mélenchon
aux dernières aux dernières élections.
Je le dis partout donc il y a pas de de
souci là-dessus. Très franchement, je
vois pas étant à gauche quel autre choix
était possible.
Euh et le média euh oui, le média il a
été fondé par deux not deux personnes
notamment qui étaient proches de
Mélenchon pendant l'incampagne. Donc je
je vais pas vous dire ce serait grosse
de vous dire on connaît pas ces gens-là.
Voilà. Maintenant moi et je vous dis la
vérité euh intérêt
vous avez l'air aimable en disant ça.
C'est pas on n'est pas là pour être
aimable. Euh, on n'est pas au poste non
plus, hein.
Euh,
derrière vous, il y a des sangles.
Méfiez-vous, hein.
Euh,
c'est bientôt la Turquie, hein,
méfiez-vous.
Ouais. Du coup, vous me faites perdre le
fil,
c'est fait exprès.
Euh,
média, Mélenchon, proximité insistie.
Non mais si vous voulez euh moi je
connais très peu mal les gens de la
France insoumise.
Je connais François Ruffin mais qui est
arrivé Chirikou elle est proche quand
même. Chikirou pardon ça dit côté disle.
J'ai rencontré Sophia Chikirou
en août 2017.
Une vraie rencontre qui m'a qui m'a
convaincu
de rejoindre le projet.
et euh et et et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
lui-même, je l'ai vu trois fois dans ma
vie et et et notamment en tant
qu'interview pour l'OPS euh à deux
reprises euh
ce qui est une position
compliquée à vivre
parce que bon, on le sait, Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
à juste titre parce qu'il est énormément
attaqué à une grande méfiance à l'égard
de cette presse là, de cette presse
mainstream
et donc les rapports peuvent être tendu.
A trois petites questions d'internet.
Pourquoi le média sur internet fait un
format qui copie ceux de la télé ?
Alors moi d'abord, je suis pas d'accord
avec ça parce queon copie pas les
formats de la télé. Parlez-moi d'un d'un
journal télévisé actuel sur France 2,
TF1 et cetera où les journalistes sont
en plateau pour défendre
leur sujet et la subjectivité de leur
point de vue. Il y en a pas.
Par ailleurs, de toute façon, pour moi,
c'est pas un argument parce que moi je
fais partie, mais on n'est pas tous
d'accord au média sur cette question,
mais moi je fais partie des gens
qui
je si vous voulez, je trouvais que ce
qui était excitant dans ce projet,
c'était justement de prendre les codes
euh du système pour les retourner contre
lui, c'est-à-dire ne pas prétendre
inventer formellement, mais montrer
qu'un euh qu'un autre JT est possible
euh
un autre point de vue est possible
et à cet égard, je suis pas absolument
pas gênée que nous ayons comme ça
emprunter le code du JT qui est
effectivement un vieil exercice. Et
cette réflexion là, moi, elle m'a été
inspirée par
ce que j'ai lu de Pablo Iglésias
quand il a fait le bilan de son
expérience de la Twerka, la chaîne donc
que les bon il avait fondé avec un
certain nombre d'amis intellectuels,
universitaires,
copains avant le déclenchement euh du
mouvement de la Puerta d'El Sol Et le
calcul est il est c'est un communiquant
redoutable. Pablo Iglesia sa, il avait
dit il est hors de et d'ailleurs si vous
regardez les images de la Twerka, c'est
très glamour, c'est très euh c'est même
c'est une espèce de show qui ressemble à
des talks dont on a l'habitude sur de
grandes chaînes et son calcul c'était
euh on va reprendre les codes auxquels
les gens sont habitués, on va pas les
déstabiliser
et on va euh prendre utiliser ces canaux
là, ce médium là pour faire passer un
autre message, un autre discours. Et euh
moi je je je à cet égard, je je soutien
totalement la décision qui a été prise
de maintenir ce JT.
Autre question, pourquoi pourquoi devoir
faire un média avec une ligne politique
?
Alors pour moi, la question elle se pose
même pas en fait parce que la politique
fait partie de ma vision du monde, de la
vie, de mon rapport aux gens. La
politique c'est quoi ? c'est pas la vie
partie d'air, c'est pas la politique
aïerie, c'est le rapport aux autres.
Comment vivre avec les autres ? Comment
vivre en collectivité ? Donc
euh moi j'ai si vous voulez dans les
dans les journaux où je suis passée
auquels vous faisiez allusion tout à
l'heure, vous avez pas cité Marianne
mais j'ai passé aussi 3 ans en tant que
directrice agente à Marianne, j'ai
énormément souffert
de
euh à l'OPS de voir une espèce de fausse
neutralité engagée qui ne correspondait
absolument pas à la réalité ce que nous
vivions et à Marianne de mettre pleurer
sur une ligne que je pensais être fran
tireur
beaucoup plus proche de moi qui en fait
malheureusement tirait de plus en plus
vers l'islamophobie et vers le le une
espèce de de de d'esprit de la écar très
rance quoi. Voilà. Moi, j'ai été
toujours en porte àfau par rapport aux
lignes
euh des médias pour lesquels j'ai
travaillé et c'est euh donc un euh un
immense un une immense libération
d'énergie et une immense joie que de
pouvoir
voilà enfin se sentir exprimé par ce
qu'on voit à l'écran et se sentir fier
de ce qu'on voit à l'écran. Et moi je
comme d'autres journalistes du milieu
qui ne ramenaient même plus les journaux
chez eux euh tellement c'est une chose
qu'on entend très couramment dans le
milieu journalistique. Je ramène même
pas le journal chez moi parce que j'ai
honte que mes proches, que mon mec, que
machin le voit. Et bien euh
je connais ce sentiment et euh et avec
le média euh chaque euh chaque chose que
je fais euh euh même coller un timbre au
médiia a pour moi un sens. Euh et je ne
pourrais pas pratiquer à nouveau ce
métier autrement.
Ça fait quoi de mettre les doigts dans
la prise comme ça ? De se réveiller avec
toutes ces illusions qui tombent ? J'ai
j'ai mangé énormément de conférences de
vous cette nuit et c'est pas la joie qui
transpire.
On sent on sent
c'est mon interprétation mais quelqu'un
de triste, quelqu'un qui
est désabusé par sa profession.
Vous avez regardé.
On vous sent vous sent au bord de la
falaise à chaque fois. Chaque bout de
phrase. C'est mon interprétation. H
euh
non.
Qu'est-ce qui vous donne espoir ? Vous
avez vu ? Ce qui vous donne espoir
quand vous regardez votre votre
profession ? Non non mais moi je suis
pas d'accord avec ce que vous dites du
tout parce que
Non mais c'est vrai. Non non mais oui
mais attends ben on parle de choses
sérieuses et pas forcément gay mais euh
euh Non parce que moi j'ai eu la
possibilité euh après ces événements de
quitter le métier en hein. J'ai eu la
chance
Non mais j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un
Renaudo. J'ai eu la chance d'avoir
comme Céline
une vague c'est vrai de sympathie
immense même d'amour de la part des gens
euh et finalement
euh euh comme le comme le dit mon ami
Alain Badiou,
il y a deux choses qui comptent et là
j'ai pu vraiment l'éprouver dans ces
moments-là, c'est les gens et l'œuvre.
Voilà hein. Œuvré ça peut être sous
différentes formes. Ça peut être en tant
qu'écrivain, ça peut être en tant que
journaliste, ça peut être en tant que
vidéaste et les gens voilà et le reste
n'a aucune importance. Et très
franchement euh n'imaginez pas, je n'ai
même pas non, j'ai pas vécu j'ai il y a
eu des les premiers mois étaient
extrêmement violents. Euh mais
l'écriture déjà que j'ai entamé très
vite a été une libération personnelle.
J'ai pris combien vous avez vendu de
livre ? Euh franchement, j'ai pas le
dernier chiffre parce que j'ai la
chance, comme c'est un sujet euh qui
intéresse énormément les gens en ce
moment, qu'il y a une crise des médias
terrible, qui est le livre continue, je
sais pas, je dirais euh 30000 quelque
chose comme ça. Euh mais ça fait
longtemps que je je pas regardé ça. Mais
euh non, donc j'ai pas eu de de de
période d'affaissement en fait. Euh mais
je pense que c'est le combat qui vous
porte et puis j'ai vraiment eu quand
même énormément de sympathies même de
gens de la profession qui pouvaient pas
la manifester publiquement mais qui ont
été là et vraiment là. Donc non, moi
j'aurais pu bifurquer à ce moment-là.
J'ai vraiment pensé, j'ai failli le
faire.
Pour faire quoi ?
Pour écrire.
Que que pour écrire ?
Pour écrire, c'est tout. Euh j'ai eu des
propositions euh de d'éditeurs, j'ai eu
des propositions d'avaloir, j'ai eu des
propositions d'enquête aussi a coécrite
avec des journalistes connus. Donc j'ai
j'ai j'étais vraiment un un je veux de
le faire quand j'ai entendu parler de du
lancement du média. Donc c'est le média
qui m'a rattrapé euh par les cheveux, si
je peux dire, euh parce que euh parce
que c'était presque fait et euh et je je
mettrai euh toutes mes forces dans ce
dans ce lancement, dans ce projet.
Après, on verra. Voilà. Mais ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que
vous avez des doutes ?
Non, je vous le dis vraiment. J'ai une
grande confiance parce que je pense que
euh comme je l'avais dit lors de notre
soirée de lancement, euh rien n'est plus
fort et plus puissant et plus
irrésistible qu'une idée quand heure est
venue. Et je pense que l'heure est venue
parce que les gens sont écurés par euh
par ce qu'on leur
montre à l'écran, parce qu'on leur donne
à lire dans la presse, que la presse,
les médias et les médias français sont à
bout de souffle,
qu'on est même dans l'obscénité quand on
ouvre certains magazines, c'est même
incroyable de d'oser encore sortir en
cufque, ça c'est je pense juste pour
justifier les salaires
aversé aux familles, les pensions de
famille Euh et donc je pense que les
gens attendent quelque chose. Alors on
commence, on le fait puis on le fait pas
toujours à droitement. On on tente des
trucs, on fera mieux. Mais je suis très
confiante, vraiment très confiante
vraiment.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
la charte de Munique ?
Euh alors la Char de Munique,
figurez-vous, je l'ai découverte euh en
2016.
Euh euh et
vous aviez votre carte de presse depuis
combien de temps ?
Ah ben alors, attendez, je vais vous
dire. J'ai j'ai ma carte de presse
depuis 2000 l'été 2000, donc je l'avais
depuis 16 ans et j'ignorais totalement
l'existence de ce texte
qui m'a donné une grande force parce que
le texte dit explicitement que c'est ça
le point le plus fort, c'est que le
journalisme
doit placer les intérêts du public
au-dessus de ceux de son de ses
employeurs, des actionnaires et même et
de l'État aussi et et voilà donc c'est
un texte extrêmement ambitieux qui fixe
la norme éthique pour notre profession
au niveau européen, mais je pense qu'il
est très utile de l'avoir en tête et de
le garder en ligne de mire et bon autant
vous dire qu'on est tellement loin
quand vous étiez à l'OPS ou quand vous
étiez ailleurs, est-ce que vous avez
senti
la laisse du pouvoir se tendre sur le
collier des journalistes ?
J'ai senti ça en fait. Alors, il y a
deux choses hein. D'abord, moi j'ai
toujours eu des problèmes. En fait, j'ai
eu des problèmes dès l'été euh de mon
embauche. Des premiers problèmes,
c'est-à-dire des relectures qui se
passent mal,
euh des des des sujets dont vous savez
très qui sont trappés, des sujets don ou
des sujets dont vous savez que ils ne
passeront jamais, donc vous ne les
proposez même pas et cetera. Donc la
frustration, elle est venue assez vite
en fait, mais moi c'était mon métier, je
l'aimais. L'OPS restait quand même un
lieu à peu près digne à cette époque-là,
ce qui n'est plus depuis longtemps. Euh
c'est-à-dire, il y avait des grands
formats.
Quand on était pas près du centre du
pouvoir, on avait une certaine latitude
et moi j'étais dans le domaine culturel
et des idées en plus. Donc c'était pas
le domaine culturel le plus sous
observation,
mais euh
c'était lesquels les plus en sur
observation ?
Bah en fait le domaine intellectuel est
très très surveillé et puis le domaine
politique naturellement. Mais après le
le truc c'est que donc il y avait
toujours ce ce malaise, ce rapport
euh pénible, douloureux parfois la
profession, mais ça restait vievable.
Après euh j'ai eu un très très gros
accrochage avec Bernard Henry Leville.
Ça paraît inimaginable que ce guignol
soit l'arbitre des élégances, mais
c'était encore le cas. Et d'ailleurs, il
est toujours au conseil de surveillance
du monde, je le signale quand même,
hein. Donc, il a toujours un pouvoir de
nuisance extrême. J'ai eu un très très
gros accrochage en 20110
avec
ce personnage puisque j'avais révélé
qu'il avait cité indument
un un Jean-Baptiste Beutule,
philosophe paraguayen qui n'existait
pas. Bon, voilà. et euh une une affaire
totalement euh délirante, indigne d'un
pays euh comme la France qui a quand
même été quelque chose
intellectuellement à une époque quand
même, il faut quand même le le rappeler.
Euh tout le monde s'en est mêlé, euh
c'est Golen Royal et Libernavi, toute la
presse m'est tombée dessus du Figaro à
Marian en passant. Enfin, ça a été
France Interre l'a invité pour montrer
son corps martyrisé et criblé de
flèches. Et euh il se trouve que notre
patron à l'époque à l'ab c'était Denis
Oliv, donc un vraiment membre typique de
l'oligarchie passé d'Air France et de la
Fnac à la direction du Nouvels, on ne
sait pas pourquoi et très proche de
cette bande de Bernardi. Et là,
j'étais mais placard disait mais c'était
même plus un placard, c'était vraiment
la femme au masque de faire quoi.
C'està-dire j'avais plus le droit de
toucher à rien, j'avais plus le droit de
toucher au dossier de une, j'avais plus
le droit de toucher aux enquêtes,
j'avais même faire un portrait
d'intellectuel
sans enjeu comme Luc Ferry m'était
interdit. Et donc, j'avais le droit de
rubriquer sur des formats timbres postes
des romans français de qualité
discutable. Voilà. Donc là euh je me
suis dit qu'il fallait vraiment faire
quelque chose et partir euh puisque là
j'ai commencé là cette année-là j'ai
souffert là. J'ai vraiment souffert.
J'ai vraiment souffert parce que ils
m'ont vraiment empêché de de travailler,
d'écrire, d'exercer mon métier. C'est
c'est vraiment Donc là j'ai là c'est à
ce moment-là que je suis partie à
Mariane. Là j'ai eu l'illusion de
trouver un lieu plus adéquate et cetera.
Illusion qui s'est brisé au bout d'un
mois.
Mais là, si vous voulez vous parler de
la de la main du pouvoir, là vous parlez
du pouvoir politique, j'imagine. Ouais.
Là, j'ai vraiment senti en revenant à
l'OPS en 2014
que euh à un poste très important cette
fois, enfin numéro 2 de directrice
adjoint, là, j'ai vraiment commencé à
comprendre que euh ma situation n'était
plus la moi j'étais la même, ma
situation n'était plus la même et que
euh un jour les choses pourraient mal
tourner.
Euh je me souviens d'une conversation
avec des camarades où j'ai qui disaient
"Mais non, Xavier Niel, il est offshore,
il s'occupe pas de ça, il est trop loin
tout ça." Euh et j'ai dit "Non, je très
franchement je pense que vous vous
trompez et je pense que notamment un an
avant une présidentielle
euh il doit se passer des choses."
Voilà, je me suis pas trompée sur ce
point.
Je ne savais pas que je serais le cobail
de cette opération.
Vous avez un avis sur les gafas ?
Euh oui,
les gafas, le journalisme, Filter
Bubble, euhou
Ouais.
Astrurfing, euh connaissez trop loin là.
Trop là, je sais pas ce que c'est.
Astrurfing, c'est poster des
commentaires soit avec des groupes, soit
avec des machines pour influencer
l'opinion publique et le le dirigerou
dans un sens ou dans l'autre. Bah
écoutez, oui, on peut avoir qu'un ma vie
en ce moment sur les gafas et leur
impact sur les médias puisque
euh c'est quand même un des grands euh
dossiers noirs et secrets actuels de la
presse française, c'est que les Facebook
par exemple, voilà, arrose les
rédactions euh françaises d'argent,
hein.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par arroser
?
Bah des
une petite pluie, une grosse pluie, ça
ruisselle fort.
Non non non, c'est une très grosse
pluie.
hein. C'est bah je sais pas pareil, moi
je me réfère à il y a une enquête source
là-dessus euh c'est celle de
euh un journaliste qui n'est pas
français d'ailleurs. Je crois que c'est
un journaliste belge qui s'appelle
Nicolas Bosquet et qui euh évoque
par exemple le fait que la moitié de la
rédaction web de LCI serait financé
serait rémunéré entièrement grâce au
fond de Facebook. Donc on est sur des
sommes considérables, on est sur des
mensualisations
de centaines de milliers d'euros
et euh les médias actuels, les
rédactions étant entre les mains de de
gens d'actionnaires financiers qui sont
dans des logiques courttermistes, qui ne
sont pas attachés au métier, qui sont là
uniquement pour des raisons d'influence
euh et Bien, ils acceptent cet argent
là, hein. Il ils acceptent de manger
avec le diable sans prendre une longue
cuillère et ils sont actuellement entrés
dans un processus de dépendance
financière tout à fait euh tout à fait
démocratiquement inquiétant puisque
évidemment ces multinationales là,
pourquoi les comparer avec le diable ?
Euh,
c'est dur. C'est dur quand même
le démon. Non, mais c'est un peu Oui,
c'est c'est une boutade et en même temps
à moitié parce que si vous voulez enfin
je vous apprends rien, je pense que
c'est un peu votre domaine
mais
c'est vrai que
euh loin de l'idéologie encore
libertaire sous le signe du cool qu'on
peut que certains ont au sujet de la
Silicon Valallley, il s'agit quand même
de logique financière prédatrice.
Il s'agit de multinational qui sont en
rapport avec l'État américain. Ça depuis
longtemps.
Est-ce que vous craignez une ingérence
de des États-Unis dans les politiques
étrangères ?
Mais ça me semble évident. Ça me semble
évident.
Autant que les Russes s'il y a de
l'ingérence russe.
Mais beaucoup plus beaucoup plus les
Russes sont des des amateurs dans cette
histoire. Ça n'en fait pas des gens
vertueux. S'ils avaient la même
la mêmes moyens à disposition, il le
feraiit. Mais si vous voulez entre en
entre un site de troll comme Spoutnik et
euh
Pourquoi vous dites que Sputnick c'est
un site de troll ? Je plaisante. Si
parce qu'il y a quand même une logique
de trollage de la société française
d'une certaine façon.
Euh c'est-à-dire insister là où ça fait
mal, euh déchirer le tissu social et
appuyer et tendre la blessure comme dit
comme dit Wellbec Michel Wellbec. Et si
ils sont dans cette logique là mais
voilà c'est une logique de puissance
d'un état étranger.
Ça a toujours existé. Il faut pas être
non plus naïf par rapport à ça. Voilà.
Mais c'est beaucoup moins pernicieux et
et et influent que la logique
américaine. Puis puisque toutes nos vies
privé, toutes nos données personnelles,
pas les vôtres mais en tout cas les
nôtres aussi un peu c'est compliqué de
garder sa de vie privée.
Voilà. Exactement. toutes nos données
personnelles, tout notre historique
de de vie, de mail, euh
de site porno,
de site porno, si vous me le dites,
euh de
toutes nos toutes tout ce qui et puis ça
va bien au-delà en fait même de cette de
cette main mise sur les données
personnelles puisque c'est même notre
fonctionnement,
c'est le côté prédictif qui vous fait
peur.
Bah, c'est-à-dire que nous sommes quand
même soumis à des suggestions
constamment dès qu'on dès qu'on navigue
sur un ordinateur
euh des suggestions dont on n pas les
tenants et les aboutissants euh et je
pense moi je ne peux pas ne pas imaginer
que tout ça n'ait pas un impact cérébral
fort sur le le la capacité d'attention,
de concentration.
Euh il y a
arbitre
absolument il y a une espèce de camisole
invisible
euh qui est qui a été apposé sur nos
esprits, sur nos cerveaux par ces euh
par ces euh voilà par cette servitude
volontaire dans laquelle on est tombé
parce que moi je on est tous plus plutôt
il s'agit pas de porter un regard sur
les autres.
Quelle est votre stratégie face à ça ?
Ben très franchement euh j'ai pas de
stratégie individuelle par rapport à ça
parce que euh j'ai un iPhone euh parce
que euh parce que pour des raisons
professionnelles, je suis obligée
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux, même si
en soit idéalement j'aimerais euh
m'extraire de ça, mais c'est pas
possible surtout c'est pas possible
quand on est dans la position du
minoritaire, du marginal parce que c'est
un une arme très puissante. On peut
mobiliser comme ça les gens hors hors
grand réseau.
Non, je vous le dis, vous avez l'air
d'vitatif. On savait pas que Audancelin
avait une armée derrière elle. C'est
vrai, les réseaux sociaux sont une force
très puissante.
Mais évidemment, mais attendez, moi euh
quand vous quand vous êtes dans la
situation où j'ai été au moins pendant
un an et demi, que vous sortez un livre
comme ça et que personne ne vous tombe
micro, il faut bien s'organiser
autrement. et euh et et euh et le bouche
à oreille et les réseaux sociaux sont
parfois beaucoup plus puissant qu'un
article dans le monde que dans le monde
des livres que plus personne n'ouvre.
Voilà.
Donc vous avez pas de stratégie pour
particulière pour protéger votre vie
privée.
Moi j'ai
votre stratégie pour résister au rleau
compresseur des gars femmes ou des BATX
vous auriez une stratégie pour votre
profession, votre cast, votre
de journaliste en général ? Mais moi
quand je vous dis j'ai pas de stratégie
personnelle,
je vous dis ça parce que je pense que
ce soit dans l'écologie ou les GAFA euh
il y a que des stratégies politiques et
à grande échelle qui peuvent être
efficaces et vraiment peser un jour sur
la donne. Donc tant qu'on aura pas un
pouvoir politique qui entamera un bras
de fer
avec les gafas pour limiter leur leur
pénétration, leur portée, rien ne
changera. Voilà. Alors après évidemment
il y a il y a quand même un travail de
pédagogie auprès des gens parce que il y
a des gens il suffit de parler une
demi-heure avec eux, ils comprennent le
danger
euh qu'ils en cours voilà en en
utilisant en allant sur ses réseaux sans
aucune limite sans conscience de ce
qu'il de ce qu'ils font. Beaucoup de
gens ignorent même que les articles sur
leur euh sur leur fil Twitter ne sont ne
sont pas sont modéré euh qu'on leur
envoie certains articles et pas d'autres
et qui ne que le fil n'est pas neutre
quoi. Donc il y a il y a pas le le le la
connaissance minimale de ce que sont ces
réseaux chez dans la population. Mais
donc la solution, elle ne peut être que
politique.
Euh pareil pour d'ailleurs les lois sur
contre la concentration des médias dans
les mains euh de 8 ou neuf personnes.
Euh il y a qu'un pouvoir qui peut
arrêter ça parce que on pense que
on pense qu'on est impuissant, qu'on a
pas de pouvoir par rapport à ça. Mais
l'État est très puissant. L'État a un
grand pouvoir. Mais il ne l'utilise pas.
il ne l'utilise pas parce que euh prenez
le le quinquena François Hollande
qui avait un un programme qui a été élu
avec un programme du PS extrêmement
ambitieux hein sur la question des
médias en 2012. C'est extrêmement drôle
de lire ce programme. Et bien, il a
ouvert les vannes à Patrick Drahi pour
le recherchet de libération de
l'Express, à Bernard Arnaud, à Vincent
Boloré qui n'a jamais été inquiété pour
ces histoires de massacre à la
tronçonneuse de Canal Plus et Télé. On a
quelques ministres qui sont allés faire
les clowns,
lesquels ?
Pour soutenir les manifestants d'itélé.
Bah en tout cas, j'ai en tête de façon
certaine
le député PS qui s'est fait battre à
plat de couture là à Paris, Patrick
Blush qui était en charge de la loi
blush sur les médias chargés par
Hollande de cette affaire qui est venu
passer la main dans le dos des
journalistes du télé en grève euh mais
qui vous raconte off que de toute façon
c'est comme ça, il faut faire avec les
grands capitalistes
Faut sauver de l'emploi.
On peut pas imaginer autre chose. Voilà.
Et c'est là qui est le pognon donc c'est
là qu'il faut gratter quoi. Voilà. Et
avec un cynisme absolu euh et
ou un pragmatisme absolu.
Moi, je dis cynisme
mais si vous voulez moi je dis cynisme
parce que je l'ai rencontré pendant la
campagne de Benoît Amont sur un plateau
de télé et il était le monsieur média du
PS.
et euh il a démoli le programme média du
candidat à PS dont il était en charge.
Donc moi, quand un parti en arrive à ce
degré de décomposition
pour tirer sur son propre candidat, là
euh voilà, c'est difficile avoir du
respect pour ces gens-là quoi.
Vous voyez la violence du du débat, la
violence qu'il y a contre les
journalistes en ce moment.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
radicaliser au de lancelin ? La
transformer en guerrière,
lui enlever ses
Vous trouvez que je suis pas
Je vous trouve sans sans jugement. Je
vous trouve trop douce.
Ouais.
Trop
Et tout le monde tout le monde est pas
de votre avis hein.
C'est vrai ?
Non.
Lesquels ? Lesquel ?
Surtout pas les gens dont j'ai fait le
portrait dans le monde libre.
Dans dans le monde libre. Press presse
écrite.
Pardon.
C'est ça. Dans la presse écrite. Vous
êtes très forte.
Non, mais si vous voulez, non, je je
écoutez, c'est peut-être un pour les
pour pour les journalistes dans le
milieu, je passe voilà pour quelqu'un
euh qui dit les choses en face et qui a
levé plein tabou sur ce milieu. Donc
euh non, moi j'ai vraiment au contraire
en écrivant ce livre déclarer une guerre
et je ça pour le coup je
c'est une guerre silencieuse. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de la la de l'approche
d'Élise Lu ?
Le côté un peu rondre dedans, le côté un
peu je vais te chercher jusque devant la
porte des toilettes.
Ben écoutez, moi je je peux que euh
Est-ce que c'est pas une stratégie qui
est plus offensive, plus productive ? Ça
c'est en tout cas elle est à votre goût.
Mais euh chacun chacun son Non mais
chacun son style. Moi, je suis pas une
si vous voulez, moi je suis avant tout
euh mon cœur de métier, c'est les idées.
Voilà hein. Et pour interviewer un
philosophe, un sociologue génial et
cetera, c'est pas en allant lui casser
la gueule dans les toilettes, à la
sortie des toilettes qu'on obtient
quelque chose. Est-ce que on obtient
plus une masse inertielle de
téléspectateurs plus importants pour se
saisir de la problématique en faisant ça
plutôt qu'en ayant une approche plus
soft power sur les idées sur le le
travail de
si vous voulez je pense je pense que
vous avez tort de mettre les deux en
concurrence ou en opposition que c'est
complèt
non moi je pense que c'est complètement
complémentaire je pense que il y a deux
choses fondamentales
et il faudra nous au médias qu'on
développe notre une cellule
d'investigation hein, on est on en
parle. Euh, il y a l'investigation et
les idées. C'est ça, c'est vraiment
l'essentiel,
le la ligne, les éditaux, les idées et
de l'autre côté l'investigation. Et ce
que fait Éise Lucé est extrêmement
précieux. Je le salue évidemment.
Les reportages sur Lidl Free et tout ont
été exemplaires et ont un impact massif.
Évidemment, quand vous êtes à la sur un
canal public, à la télé publique, vous
touchez des millions de gens. Et
j'espère et je souhaite de tout cœur que
ça continue. Et je me suis mobilisée euh
à l'époque pour que quand les émissions
d'enquête du service public étaient
menacé pour qu'on les pour que pour que
le pouvoir recule.
Euh question d'internet. Euh,
est-ce que le média serait-il prêt à
être fait checké par les internautes ?
Question.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là ?
C'est une question de lunette. Est-ce
que est-ce que le média serait prêt à
voir par exemple décodex financé par
Facebook fa checker le le média ?
Ah ben il nous ils passent leur journée
à nous fa checker. Vous rigolez ou quoi
? Euh
on se fait l'avocat du diable. Il nous
il nous f check à l'œil d'ailleurs en
dehors de leurs heures de bureau. On est
sous surveillance permanente hein.
Veille si vous voulez. Bon
vous avez un avis sur le décodex ?
Ah oui oui moi je l'ai donné partout je
l'ai
on va le redonner là alors.
Ouais ouais je Bah non mais c'est c'est
carrément
inimaginable qu'un journal se
s'autoinvestisse de la mission de juger
ses confrères de distribuer des bons
points des points de bonne conduite et
tout. C'est c'est il faut vraiment être
le monde, c'est-à-dire un journaliste du
monde, c'est se prendre pour le sel de
la terre pour imaginer un truc aussi
délirant. Non mais je veux dire même le
Figaro ferait jamais ça par exemple.
C'est intéressant de comprendre pourquoi
la droite ferait pas ça. La droite
ferait pas ça parce que il faut vraiment
être avoir toute la bonne conscience
hypocrite d'un social démocrate français
pour se lancer dans une dans une affaire
pareille en toute bonne conscience parce
que je suis
c'est pas nécessaire avec toute la je
vais dire le tout le brouillard des des
fausses informations de
des des euh des gourous du net autour de
de sujets euh un peu nébuleux. C'était
pas nécessaire qu'il y ait un petit une
petite cellule collégiale qui qui donne
un point de repère, un phare. Moi, je
suis beaucoup plus inquiète
euh quand la liberté d'expression est
bloquée et filtrée par les par les
salariés de Xavier Niel que quand
une une forme de n'importe quoi et
d'écumes mensongères circulent, c'est on
n'empêchera jamais ça. Euh voilà, c'est
c'est comme ça. à toutes les époques,
vous vous trouvez les fausses nouvelles,
les rumeurs, les machins. Bon, alors il
y a sans doute des choses à faire, mais
comment on fait pour bloquer la
propagation d'une rumeur ?
Bonne question. Euh,
on explique, on patiemment, on se bat,
mais bon, on ne on ne
on ne filtre pas. Euh une entreprise
privée ne peut pas comme ça euh aider
une autre entreprise privée. Le monde ne
peut pas aider Facebook à à filtrer le
les bonnes pensées des mauvaises
pensées. C'est c'est totalement évident
à mes yeux.
Autre question de de l'internet. Euh
est-ce qu'un média peut-il être
au-dessus d'une voix politique ?
Vous pouvez me décrypter ? déchiffrer.
Euh on va passer à la prochaine. RT
propose la contrepropagande comme le
média.
Est-ce que est-ce que le média propose
une contrepropagande à un prisme de
lecture libéral, archilibéral ? une
contrepropage. Euh j'espère que ça ne
signifie pas, aux yeux de la personne
qui écrit une autre propagande, une
propagande en miroir. Non, l'objectif
c'est évidemment euh pas ça.
Est-ce que c'est parce que les
journalistes n'ont pas fait leur travail
depuis des décennies que ça laisse le
champ libre à toutes les formes de
propagande parce que l'esprit critique
de la population a été
érodé par
on va dire une passivité intellectuelle
des journalistes ?
Non, mais c'est un processus de
décomposition long, hein. Ça fait cette
histoire là, elle court depuis les
années 50, quoi. Faut voir dans le long
terme. Euh ça s'est pas fait en un jour
et puis les journalistes sont pas
coupables en tant que classe.
Euh c'est aussi tout un tout écosystème
qui a
acclimaté les gens à l'idée que qui
s'est fourvoyé, qui a fait axe de
fortfeture.
Je dirais même pas ça parce que
euh la les la question de la
responsabilité individuelle est pas très
intéressante dans cette histoire. Je euh
on pourrait dire c'est des traîtres.
Mais moi je je trouve la question des
médias, elle a commencé à devenir
intéressante quand on a lâché les
journalistes en tant qu'individuel, traî
salot, machin et qu'on commence à voir
l'écosystème économique et quel
qu'est-ce qui fait que ces gens-là euh
comme des comme un seul homme défendent
le même les mêmes opinions, la même
ligne ?
La main qui nourrit.
Oui, il faut regarder, il faut follow
the monnaie
euh pour comprendre ce qui se passe.
Donc et ça, je trouve que on est
maintenant dans ce sujet-là. Euh il y a
quand même des gens qui portent cette ce
discours là qui sont devenus plus
audibles.
Je pense que l'année 2016 a été assez
importante à cet égard. Il y a eu
l'affaire Itélé, il y a eu mon affaire,
il y a eu le livre de Laurent Moduit sur
main basse sur la presse française et
cetera et je rencontre dans le dans le
milieu beaucoup plus de journalistes
lucides par rapport à leur situation
alors qu'il était quasiment impossible
d'avoir cette conversation dans le
milieu il y a quelques années.
Ils étaient dans le déni
même porte fermée. Oui. Oui. Oui. Ils
étaient dans le déni
porte fermée. il voyait pas le problème.
Et et maintenant du fait aussi bien sûr
de la popérisation du milieu euh des
plans sociaux qui se succèdent
de des tarifs de pige hallucinants. Il
faut savoir qu'on maintenant on peut
avoir une carte de presse avec un demi
êre déclaré journaliste professionnel
simplement avec un demiic. Ça vous dit
ça vous en dit long sur
l'état du milieu.
C'est combien de SMIC ?
Non non on n'est pas chez Bourdin ici.
Non non je vais pas jouer avec ça. On
n'est pas à l'école ni chez Bourdin.
Next.
Le média a-t-il pour but de soutenir un
candidat à de prochaines élections ?
Question d'internet.
Est-ce que c'est une future Est-ce que
c'est un futur passeur de soupe ?
Je vais vous dire non et personne va me
croire. C'est ça. Je
Non, moi je dit déjà au moment du
lancement parce qu'on m'avait chargé
d'aller dans les médias assur
avec d'autres avec Gérard Millard et
Sophien.
Euh
ça c'est certain que le média veut faire
gagner la gauche dès 2022. Euh
bon courage.
Ouais. Mais
comment vous voyez la situation
économique évoluer ? Comment vous voyez
la situation géopolitique évoluer ?
Hm
la situation géopolitique
elle est très très inquiétante. Euh
on a on a un une véritable peau de
grayère en Syrie où toutes les
puissances mondiales s'entrecroisent.
Euh moi je je pense que
l'événement nous nous
précède toujours. On ne peut pas on peut
absolument pas dire ce qui va se passer.
Il y a une situation de crise majeure
objective,
une poudrière même financière puisque
quand même les meilleurs spécialistes
nous annoncent une crise pour dans pas
longtemps. Mais
c'est qui les meilleurs spécialistes ?
bah
des économistes
qui ont anticipé et qui avaient
anticiper eux la crise de de 2008 et en
tout cas qui ont perçu très rapidement
les conséquences durables qu'elle allait
avoir hein et que c'était absolument pas
un épiphénomène.
Euh il y en a il y en a pas mal mais euh
euh je pense que je c'est pas du il faut
faire attention au savapétisme comme on
dit. Euh mais
je
ça sent le sapin quoi.
Ouais.
Financièrement parlant et ça comment
votre lecture sur les marchés financiers
? Est-ce que vous connaissez la
hyperfancy trading ? Est-ce que vous
connaissez ?
Mais là, je m'avancerai pas sur la
question des marchés financiers qui est
très technique.
Et non, ça je je je j'essaie toujours de
ne pas parler de ce que j'ignore
totalement.
Le pic énergétique, ça vous parle ?
Non.
Le rapport Midose, ça vous parle ?
Quel est le nom de la du président de la
banque centrale américaine ?
Ça recommence.
Ouais,
on est à l'école
presque
un trivial. Non, j'ai j'ai pas son nom.
On est au trivial poursuite là.
Ouais, mais on va arrêter de jouer au
trivial poursuite là.
C'est vrai.
Vous aimez pas
le trivial poursuite ? Ça fait longtemps
que j'ai pas joué mais grâce à vous, je
recule. 10 ans.
La propagande doit-elle être combattue
avec une autre propagande ?
Non, clairement non. Non. La propagande
doit être combattue en
sur le terrain des idées.
Oui. En éveillant l'esprit des gens, en
leur rendant la liberté, le libre usage
de leur esprit. Et moi, par exemple,
j'ai toujours été hyper marquée par la
phrase de Roël sur l'esprit de
gramophone. Gramophone, c'est-à-dire
tournaudiste, hein, je le dis pour les
plus jeunes qui nous écoutent. Euh,
d'où le titre Les disquillés quand vous
passez au théâtre du Rondpoint, c'est ça
? Oui. C'est-à-dire que en fait
euh ce qui est
avilissant pour les pour l'esprit, c'est
euh
que l'on c'est c'est l'esprit de
gramophone. C'est-à-dire
il y a rien de plus déprimant d'ailleurs
àar qu'un qu'un qu'un militant qui
annonne la ligne du parti. Vous savez à
l'avance qu'il va dire. Il y a il y a
pas de surprise. C'est c'est
on les adore, on les croise le samedi
matin au marché.
Ouais.
Tom sur nous, ils changent de couleur.
Pourquoi ils ont des raisons de changer
le trottoir ?
Ils sont pas équipés au niveau de leur
source pour jouer avec nous.
Et bien, vous m'en direz plus un jour.
Euh et euh
que l'on soit d'accord ou pas avec le
disque, que l'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec la ligne, euh ne raisonner qu'en
fonction de la ligne est vraiment la
pire chose qui puisse arriver à un
esprit quoi. Donc non, je clairement
non.
Vous avez des idées pour combattre la
politique de contre-adicalisation, du
moins des idées de politique de
contreradicalisation.
Vous voulez dire
quand on voit des jeunes en désérance ne
plus avoir confiance et rentrer en
politique de défiance face au
journalistes au gouvernement.
Votre position face à ça c'est vous avez
des idées pour pouvoir les je vais pas
dire les ramener dans le droit chemin
mais au moins qu'ils évitent de venir de
devenir sourd à autre chose que
l'envie de se radicaliser.
Mais ils ont raison. Pourquoi pour non,
ils ont ils ont raison de Pourquoi
voulez-vous que ces gens-là euh écoutent
les médias, s'informe avec ces médias,
qui ne leur parlent pas, qui ne parlent
pas d'eux,
qui ne travaillent pas pour eux, qui
travaillent contre eux ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il ferait ça ? Ce
serait vraiment de la connerie. Donc
non, ces gens-là, évidemment qu'il faut
les récupérer. Il faut les récupérer.
Et
comment ?
Moi, je participe pas à à un média dont
l'ambition est de devenir le lieu
tendance pour les bobos
euh parisien. Notre notre véritable
ambition, c'est vraiment de parler
au ruraux, de parler au banlieu de euh
de leur révéler ce qu' ce qu'on leur
fait, euh ce que les gouvernements
successifs leur font.
Euh on a par ailleurs cette question m'a
été récemment posée dans un débat
comment récupérer les quartiers
populaires depuis
avec une fracture qui ne cesse de
grandir depuis 2005.
Euh nous on a une rédaction euh dont
beaucoup de membres sont dont certains
membres en tout cas sont issus de ces
quartiers, ont vécu des discrimination
raciales. Quand ils parlent de ça, ils
savent très exactement de quoi il
parlent et très franchement
proportionnellement vous trouvez pas une
rédaction équivalente sur la place.
C'est paritaire.
C'est paritaire pour le moment.
Question d'internet. Pourquoi Noël maère
a quitté le média ?
Alors, je pense que ça se passait très
très bien avec Noël ma mère. Moi, à
titre personnel, j'ai vraiment aimé
travailler avec lui puisqueon on faisait
tous les deux des interviews
d'intellectuel, de politique et on se
répartissait les
invités. Ça
pourquoi avoir pris Noël ma mère une
vieille t
Alors écoutez ça je vous détends tout de
suite c'est pas moi qui l'ai choisi mais
euh
mais je je je dois dire que c'était une
personne très charmante et euh Noël ma
mère a quitté le média parce que Noël ma
mère est arrivée au média grâce à Audre
signeux avec elle. C'est un ami
personnel de sa famille et cetera et il
a été pris dans un conflit de loyauté.
ce qui est tout à son honneur. Moi, je
l'amitié est une valeur que je respecte.
Euh et il a jugé qu'il qu'il serait
absolument grossier et inélégant euh
étant arrivé avec elle de la laisser
partir seule. Voilà. Fin de l'histoire.
Vous avez vous avez lu la critique de
Pierre Carl contre le média ?
Non. Ah si, attendez. Oui, ça me dit
quelque chose. C'était déjà il y a
quelques semaines.
Oh ouais, il y a il y a longtemps.
Ouais.
C'est vitriol quand même.
Ouais. Rafraîchissez-moi la mémoire
de tête. Je demande d'ailleurs à la
communauté de FAC qui est en live de
tête. Il disait que le média ça allait
allit nulle part. Vous refaites de la la
c'était de la souptiède fait avec
Et Pierre car il va où en fait lui ?
Parce que
parce que c'était une critique légitime.
Pourquoi vous avez pas pris plus des
têtes brûlées de l'internet pour euh
pour faire quelque chose de plus
acidulé, même piquant, même plus
percutant
pour refaire Crimè en image ou
Crimè, c'est pas percutant. Crimè, c'est
gentil.
Non, mais oui, mais attendez, je je je
vous fais confiance, mais qu'est-ce que
vous appelez euh un format Qu'est-ce que
vous appelez un format percutant ?
Bah plus, je dirais comme le fil d'actu
ou des choses comme ça.
Ouais.
qui qui sont déjà bien installés dans
les YouTube game qui on qui ont déjà une
qui qui vont avec les dents quand même.
Non mais moi je je vais vous dire très
franchement Pierre Carl euh la
sociologie est un sport de combat. Je
l'ai défendu.
Ça nous ramène à notre sujet initial à
l'OPS sur quatre pages au point de me
faire convoquer et tabassé moralement
par Laurent Geoffrein. Euh tout qui
disait au même moment "Comme tu le sais,
je n'ai pas de liste noire mais enfin on
ne parlera jamais de Pierre Carles dans
ce journal et cetera et cetera". Bon
donc euh je sais que ce qu'il l'a fait à
certains moments
euh a de la valeur mais très franchement
quand il tire dans le dos du média comme
ça, il est dans un très mauvais rôle à
l'unisson de toute une gauche radicale
actuelle.
Pourquoi vous dites qu'il tire ? Il tire
pas, il donne des conseils ? Non, ça
s'appelle pas dire ça va nulle part
donner un conseil s'appelle
Je sais pas s'il a dit ça. Non mais
attendez, je connais par cœur cette
mouvance là euh qui est quand même faite
de haine recuite, de jalousie euh aussi
qui qui c'est un milieu aussi qui vomit
Mélenchon
et donc comme les mainstream nous
assimilent à Mélenchon, ils le vomissent
par principe. Donc tout ça n'est pas
très clair. Après franchement, moi il y
a des critiques que je suis tout à fait
capable d'entendre. Si Henry Maler, le
patron d'Acrimède,
bonjour Henry,
me disait un certain nombre de choses.
Vous devriez
diversifier ça, vous devriez aller dans
telle direction, je l'écouterai parce
que je sais que c'est quelqu'un euh qui
tient des positions dures depuis
longtemps et qui est bienveillant pour
l'intérêt général
et qui est bienveillant, voilà, et qui
sert voilà, absolument qui sert
l'intérêt général et qui sert pas sa
boutique. Voilà. Je suis pas sûre que
tout le monde soit aussi bien
intentionné dans le milieu chez nos amis
de la gauche radicale.
Vous l'avez déjà invité, je crois, au
lancement du média. Non,
mal l'air. Il est venu. Ouais.
Ouai,
il est venu. Ouais.
On va on va revenir sur le le traitement
du terrorisme par les par les médias.
Euh vous le média, vous allez faire du
reportage de terrain, pas de terrain.
Vous avez une lecture sur ce que fait le
pouvoir pour
endiguer le terrorisme. Vous avez une
lecture sur la politique étrangère de la
France ? Bah moi d'abord je peux pas
vous énoncer la ligne du média comme ça
parce qu'elle c'est elle est collective
et ça par exemple typiquement c'est un
sujet sur lequel on n pas eu à discuter
là je vous rappelle qu'on est lancé
depuis moins d'un mois et demi hein.
Donc voilà. Bon évidemment il est
question de faire du terrain. Il y en a
déjà qui a été fait. Pour ça il faudra
quand même développer la rédaction parce
que tout ça a un coût
important.
Euh sur la question du terrorisme, vous
savez, moi j'ai vu ça dans une autre
rédaction à l'OPS que j'ai vécu pendant
les attentats, hein, Charlie Hebdo et le
Bataclan, la plupart des coups des
scoupes qui arrivent arrivent
directement
de la place Govu euh où arrive parce
qu'il y a des querelles entre le raid et
la gendarmerie et que
il y en a qui finissent par balancer et
cetera. C'est pas des enquêtes de
terrain qui vous donnent accès à ce type
d'information. Voilà. Mais pour ça, oui,
il faut avoir installé une réputation.
Il faut que des gens vous fassent
confiance pour diffuser ces informations
là.
Quand vous êtes vous avez été approché
pour faire le média, est-ce qu'il y a
une stratégie façon Carl von Closwiitz
qui a été établi ? Est-ce que vous avez
un cap ? Est-ce que vous avez anticipé
certaines choses ?
Est-ce que vous êtes en mode phalange
romaine ou
ou est-ce que vous vous laissez pousser
par le vent ?
Non, on peut pas se laisser pousser par
le vent quand on a tout le système
contre soi et qu'on est euh une
trentaine. C'est pas possible. Il faut
il faut avoir une stratégie
euh beaucoup plus et je ne vous la
livrerai pas ici. Euh vous m'en
excuserez. Euh pourquoi
bah parce que nous nous c'est c'est il
s'agit vraiment d'une guerre d'image,
d'une guerre de position. Euh
ces gens nous nous veulent vraiment
notre peau, hein. C'est c'est c'est pas
une blague. Donc
propre comme au figuré.
Non, au figurer bien sûr. Mais
mais euh mais c'est pas un jeu tout ça.
On n'est pas en train de lancer. On
n'est pas des youtubeurs. On n'est pas
en train de de s
Pourquoi ? C'est quoi des YouTubeurs ?
Non, on n'est pas en train de s'amuser
sur un canapé parce que on est le
champion de la de la blague et que et
que voilà, c'est vraiment ce que ce
qu'on fait, c'est un c'est un combat
journalistique, politique pour pour
rendre aux gens
euh leur liberté, leur pouvoir. Donc euh
et nous et nous nous contestons
frontalement sans nous cacher euh les
autorités. Donc évidemment que c'est
sérieux. C'est sérieux tout ça ?
Vous pensez que
on n'est pas là pour faire un show, pour
faire un
Vous pensez que vous allez avoir une
fiche S ? Vous pensez vous pensez être
écouté vous, votre conjoint peut-être ?
Euh
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des écoutes
sur les journalistes ?
Je sais qu'elles existent.
Euh moi, j'ai eu des informations comme
quoi ça avait été le cas euh
au moment de Nuit debout par exemple
avec des conséquences pour moi
professionnelles extrêmement lourdes.
Euh voilà, maintenant c'est pas quelque
chose auquel je pense au quotidien.
Euh mais enfin, il faut pas non plus
être complètement
naïf. Il y a des il y a des messageries
sécurisées pour certaines choses.
Vous utilisez quoi ?
Telégram
et en boîte mail autre genre Proton, des
choses comme ça ?
Non.
Euh question question d'Internet.
Euh très bien ça. Les subventions des
journaux français par l'État sont-elles
une bonne chose ?
Non. Euh en tout cas
euh euh là on a quand même une situation
où les principaux journaux qui touche
sont ceux précisément qui sont détenus
par les plus grands groupes industriels,
hein, que ce soit le monde, le groupe le
monde euh ou Serge d'assaut.
Donc on est vraiment dans dans
l'obscénité totale euh parce que non
seulement sont ces gens-là sont des
oligarques au sens propre du terme,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont fait leur
fortune sur des biens autrefois communs
qui ont été privatisés mais en plus
l'État leur donne de l'argent. Donc là
on arrive quand même dans un système
complètement fou. Donc évidemment, il y
a une grosse réforme à entreprendre des
aides à la presse,
des pistes
et puis euh il faut déjà commencer par
supprimer toutes les aides à la presse
euh people euh euh qui touche hein euh
et puis euh
il y a quelqu'un qui a qui a très bien
documenté cette affaire et proposé des
la piste actuellement la plus sérieuse,
c'est Pierre Rimbert du monde
diplomatique
euh qui a élaboré un projet de de
refonte des aides auquel je souscris
entièrement
qui est disponible sur internet
gratuitement.
Le média compte demander des subventions
?
Euh le média pour le moment n'a pas de
subvention.
Est-ce qu'il compte en demander ?
Je ne sais pas.
Le CSA, vous avez un avis ?
Bah encore une autorité de régulation
qui dysfonctionne complètement, qui ne
qui est totalement impuissante, enfin
qui a servi à faire sauter le patron
radio France récemment mais dans des
conditions quand même très opaques. Je
voudrais pas réhabiliter ce garçon, mais
enfin, on se demande pourquoi
c'est à ce moment précis que le CA est
pris de vertu
à considérer que que que qu'il devait
immédiatement
quitter son bureau, tout ça. Et voilà.
Ouais. Encore une chose à changer, mais
tout est à changer dans le milieu des
médias en France. Euh on est vraiment
revenu euh entièrement
à la période d'avant-guerre avec une
presse entièrement
corrompue, tenue
euh et on peut pas se satisfaire
on peut pas se satisfaire d'une
situation pareille quand on aime la
liberté.
Vous avez un avis sur les écoles de
journalisme. Est-ce qu'elles font bien
leur boulot ? Est-ce qu'elles forment
des des futurs petits requins ?
Non, surtout des petits soldats plus que
des petits requins. Euh plutôt des
Playmobil en fait.
Euh
on a vu tour, ça ressemblait pas à des
Playmobil.
Vous vouliez que je je sorte la
mitrailleuse ? Euh non,
vous voulez qu'on sorte la nôtre ?
Je sais pas de quelle nature elle est.
Donc euh
efficace.
Euh non. Euh moi j'ai la chance de pas
avoir fait d'école de journaliste.
Euh
vous avez le parcours parfait de la
femme de tête.
Vous êtes passé par Henri ? Non. Ou
quelque chose comme ça. Ensuite vous
avez fait ESCP,
c'est ça ?
J'ai fait euh un master média le SCP de
4 mois.
Et donc
bah donc
j'en attendais n'ayant aucun contact
dans les médias, ne venant pas du tout
d'une famille de médiacrate et tout. Euh
ça m'a permis de faire des rencontres,
d'obtenir des stages. Voilà. Après ça,
c'est pas le c'est pas des lieux où on
apprend des choses. Euh et les écoles de
journalistes, ça enlève rien à la valeur
de plein de gens qui en sortent. Mais je
pense que cette valeur là, ils l'ont
acquise ailleurs que dans ces écoles.
Euh sans formation intellectuelle autre,
euh si vous ne faites que ça, euh vous
êtes totalement
à la mercie de de vos patrons, c'est
tout. mettre sur tous les plans
d'ailleurs hein, que ce soit
salarialement ou
intellectuellement. Quel sur quel peut
être votre point d'appui par rapport à
au flot continu de propagande déversée
sur vous en premier lieu et sur la
population en second au second plan ?
Comment il faut les former ?
Moi je pense que ça s'apprend pas en
école le journaliste. Moi les meilleurs
journalistes que j'ai connu dans mon
parcours,
lesquels ? Ben c'était des autodidactes
complets parfois. Euh le plus moi le
plus impressionnant, le plus brillant
que j'ai connu c'était un grand reporter
de l'UPS qui s'appelait les François
Caviglioli qui est mort maintenant et
euh qui était passé par l'Express Paris
Match euh combat qui a fait des
reportages en Asie du Sud-Est ou des
portraits
de figure du showbiz parisien. Donc il y
avait une gamme très large et c'était un
esprit absolument original qui s'est
formé par les lectures sur par les
rencontrre,
par les blessures, par la prise de
conscience.
Euh
dans son cas, je sais pas, mais
euh euh c'est quelqu'un qui avait même
connu le temps de les derniers feux de
combat, le qui avait été condamné pour
offense au chef de l'État
sous de Gaulle. Euh
et moi je pense que j'ai toujours eu
essayé là où j'étais de promouvoir les
parcours originaux, les autodidactes,
les gens différents et cetera qui
apportent énormément.
Un avis sur Miapart.
Alors, Mediapart euh c'est le projet de
presse le plus impressionnant des 10
dernières années. Euh avoir réussi à
créer comme ça exilo, une telle force de
frappe euh c'est très impressionnant.
Là, il faut euh
qu'on l'aime ou pas, il faut saluer la
vista de Plainel, hein, qui a opté pour
le payant tout de suite. Tous ceux qui
avaient opté pour le gratuit sans casser
la gueule et euh qui a fait les bons
choix, c'est-à-dire on ne souspaye pas
les journalistes,
euh on les prend
à des salaires assez confortables. On ne
on applique vraiment
au niveau des RH ce que nos valeurs nous
dicte. On n'est pas dans ce faux
semblant là.
On a on insiste sur l'investigation, on
insiste sur les intellectuels. Moi tout
ça me va. Voilà. Après sans doute
Miapard vit-il qui est déjà devenue une
institution vit-il une espèce de crise
de croissance que toutes les
institutions déjà importantes vivent ?
Euh, ils ont 100000 abonnés, ils ont 80
journalistes, c'est une rédaction
énorme. Euh et donc euh
voilà. Bon, après ça, moi je je sur la
ligne politique,
j'ai été un peu dérouté, je veux dire,
par leur campagne présidentielle, hein.
Moi, il y a des questions que je me
pose, mais
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour le
projet lui-même.
C'est quoi les questions que vous vous
posez ? Moi, j'ai pas du tout compris le
l'utilité de faire venir Emmanuel
Macron, notamment à la veille du premier
tour. Euh je je
je suis très déroutée par ce choix
éditorial.
Euh et
euh je suis déroutée aussi par
l'agressivité dont le journal a fait
constamment preuve à l'égard de la
France insoumise. Je suis d'autant plus
déroutée par ça que beaucoup de leurs
lecteurs sont de ce camp là et eux-mêmes
se posent des questions. Voilà.
Vous avez des chiffres ? D'où viennent
les chiffres du fait qu'ils aient
beaucoup de d'insoumis dans leurs
abonnés ? Non, j'ai pas de chiffre mais
il suffit de Moi, j'ai eu une émission
euh plusieurs années sur Mediapart avec
Alain Badou et il suffit d'aller se
balader sur les commentaires de
Mediapart, sous les articles ou sous les
émissions pour voir que euh
que les gens de la France insoumise
étaient très actifs sur les réseaux. Oui
et puis non mais que les lecteurs sont
plus à gauche que la rédaction ce qui
est quand même un problème pour un
pour un titre de pas être totalement en
phase avec son lectat.
Que pensez une question d'internet. Que
pensez-vous de la création d'un conseil
de déontologie des des médias ?
La proposition de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
peut-être. Ouais, exact.
Ouais, c'est ça. Ouais.
Il y a pas que lui, je pense.
Si c'est ça vient de lui, hein, je
crois. Mais euh non, moi j'ai j'étais
pas j'étais pas pour j'ai pas signé la
pétition. Euh mais c'est peut-être par
excès de pessimisme parce que je ne
pense pas ça reviendrait à mettre des
journalistes et aussi bon des gens
lambda en position de juger le travail
d'autres journalistes. Moi, je leur fais
pas assez confiance pour ça. Je pas
envie de me retrouver un jour devant un
tribunal populaire de journalistes. Donc
je pense pas que ça puisse fonctionner
comme ça. Et je pense que les vrais ce
qui tue le milieu est d'ordre économique
et idéologique.
Que veut dire la carte de presse
aujourd'hui ?
Est-ce que c'est la carte qui permet
d'acheter des machines à laver moins
cher ou est-ce que ça
écoutez, j'aimerais bien mais je euh je
ne crois pas en tout cas. Euh
acheter des machines à laver moins cher
avec une carte de presse.
Si si ça existe.
Ouais ben moi j'ai je l'ai payé plein
pot euh je me déprou mal. Euh
les voitures aussi ? Non
non. la carte de presse, il y a
l'abattement fiscal hein bien sûr. Et
puis il y a euh
il faut qu'on en parle de ça, ce fameux
le prestige
le fameux abattement fiscal de des des
journalistes, c'est quand même une niche
fiscale aussi, non ?
Vous voyez bien qu'il y a une anomalie.
Si si même un pouvoir
aussi près de ses sous ne la supprime
pas, c'est que il n'est pas prêt à ce
bras de fer là avec la corporation. S'il
n'est pas prêt à ce bras de faire là,
c'est parce qu'il marche dans la main
main dans la main avec sa corporation.
Mais il n'y a pas il n'y a plus compte
vous connaissez le le principe de cet
abattement fiscal, c'est la ce qui fait
la spécificité, ça ça tend à établir une
spécificité du métier journaliste et que
financièrement, il doit être
indépendant, des pouvoirs et cetera.
Vous voyez bien que maintenant ça c'est
une vaste blague. Donc il n'y a plus de
raison morale ou pratique à cet
abattement fiscal. Il y a plus que la
lâcheté du pouvoir face au journaliste.
Autre question d'internet. Le chemin
logique d'un journaliste est-il de
passer ensuite par la politique comme
Ruffin ?
Oui, mais Ruffin, il a toujours pratiqué
un journalisme extrêmement engagé de
depuis le début euh si vous voulez.
Euh et puis Ruffin, il est pas membre de
la France insoumise, hein. C'est quand
même un électron libre encore. Euh il
est membre du groupe parlementaire, mais
il est pas c'est pas un insoumis au sens
formel partidaire du terme. Donc euh
non, moi je pense que moi je ne souhaite
pas faire de politique. C'est une
question qui a pu se poser aussi.
Euh je je euh je trouve plus enfin je
plus important euh je suis plus apte à
intervenir sur le débat d'idée euh et à
garder aussi une une forme de distance
par rapport au au logique de camp, aux
logiques partisanes. Euh je me connais
trop bien. Je sais très bien que en plus
à partir d'un du moment où un camp
arrive au pouvoir, il y a de fortes
chances pour que je bascule dans
l'opposition
au sens où il y a toujours le pouvoir,
c'est l'abus très souvent et donc une
vigilance s'impose toujours par rapport
au pouvoir. Même quand c'est votre camp
qui est au pouvoir, il faut il faut
avoir ça vraiment en tête. Même quand
c'est vos amis dans une entreprise qui
sont au pouvoir, il faut toujours euh
garder en tête que le pouvoir est le
pouvoir et euh et avoir un recul par
rapport à ça.
On fait on fait comment pour vous
débaucher du média ?
Là, très franchement,
ce serait
hors de question euh envisageable
tellement mon engagement est fort dans
ce projet, mais
euh je ne vois aucun projet à l'heure
actuelle dans dans le dans le champ
médiatique qui pourrait m'offrir
euh cette libertélà. Donc non.
Sinon on vous propose.
Je m'en se connais pas assez.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu de nous ?
pas grand-chose.
Trois personnes silencieuses.
Nos productions.
Ah, j'ai vu
j'ai vu l'entretien de Frédéric Tadi.
J'ai plus la liste, faudrait que vous me
la lisiez. Mais il y a quelques noms qui
m'ont surpris dans vos choix.
Lesquels ?
Ben justement, si vous me le dites,
ça parlait de quoi ?
Il faudrait me dire vos vos derniers
entretiens.
Pablo Servigne,
ouais, ça c'est bien.
On a fait qui d'autre ? On a fait Lord
d'Espéranceza, vous marrez pas les gars.
Idriss
Idriss Abercan.
Euh, on a fait euh Stigler,
Cann
et euh Clin pardon.
Clin Étienne Clin.
Ouais.
On a fait qui d'autre ?
David Koubi et Jean-Pierre Canet. Merci
mec. Euh, on a fait euh Xenia Fedorova,
Philippe Bwix, L24 Sébastien Arsac.
On a fait euh quelques politiques, du
moins un politique de de d'hidalgo sur
la pollution. On a fait euh Vilani, on a
fait Jeancovici, on a fait Mathieu, on a
fait Mounir Majoui, on a fait
bon des gens comme ça. On a aussi euh
Olivier de la Marche, Étienne Cho
Marissa.
C'était bien Mounir.
Il fait ce qu'il peut.
Est-ce qu'il a conservé un peu de
liberté de parole ?
Il fait ce qu'il peut. Il bosse
beaucoup. il nous a épuisé parce que
quand on a préparé le l'interview, il
nous a épuisé mais il fait ce qu'il
peut. On connaît son biotop
je peux vous dire du moin on peut vous
dire qu'il essaie de faire il essaie de
nager au milieu d'un énorme banc de
requin.
Donc vous avez vu quoi ?
J'en ai vu très peu
de nous.
Ouais.
Donc c'était lesquels que vous avez vu ?
Je peux pas vous dire franchement j'ai
vu que des extraits. Je vous ai
identifié tout à fait visuellement.
Mais j'ai jamais regardé un entretien en
entier.
Si on vous propose de faire de
l'investigation avec nous, vous venez ?
Je vous ai répondu.
Donc c'est que le média pour l'instant.
Ouais.
Vos prétentions sal à l'arial, c'est
combien ?
Modeste, je vous l'ai dit,
3750 €.
Vous m'augmentez alors ?
Je cette question là n'a jamais été la
mienne. Ce qui on peut penser ce qu'on
veut.
Moi euh
vous aura que aux valeurs, pas au salur.
Non mais c'est vrai surtout au après
avoir traversé ça, c'est totalement Mais
de toute façon, moi le le j'ai jamais
cherché de poste hiérarchique. J'ai
essayé de de me sauver des emmerdes que
j'avais dans mon travail par la voie
hiérarchique. Ça n'a rien à voir.
C'est-à-dire, j'ai pensé que en
acceptant un poste à responsabilité, je
pourrais enfin ne pas être constamment
contrôlé, surveillé et pouvoir passer
beaucoup plus de de
textes et de de sujets
en avec lesquels je sois d'accord.
Voilà. Et et c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté de monter dans la hiérarchie.
Mais sur le fond,
les positions hiérarchiques sont une
servitude énorme. Vous vous avez
l'impression d'être dépossédé de
vous-même. Et euh moi, je me suis déjà
retrouvé dans des situations où vous
êtes à disposition de tout le collectif.
Il y a quelqu'un euh
quelqu'un entre dans votre bureau toutes
les 3 minutes pour vous faire signer un
truc, vous poser une question, vous
soumettre à un sujet, discuter, prend
perdre son temps, que sais-je ? Voilà.
Et euh
je n'ai jamais euh goûté ces positions
là. Jamais.
Est-ce que vous avez des choses à
rajouter ?
Je crois qu'on a fait un bon tour là, je
sais pas. Est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Lire. Lire, il faut lire beaucoup.
Lire quoi ?
Trois bouquins. Conseiller trois
bouquins.
Ah,
un philosophe.
Ouais. Le gay savoir de Nietzsche
pas mal. Quoi d'autre ?
Un philosophe.
Autre chose.
Il faut lire Pasolini.
Il faut lire
Orel, il faut lire Dostoyevski,
Pascal Pauli. Non,
vous me le conseillez.
Je sais pas, vous avez déjà lu ?
Non.
Pas d'autres conseils pour les jeunes
générations.
Il faut
en dépit de envers ces années,
ces dizaines d'années de contre
réévolution qu'on a vécu, il faut
retrouver le sens du combat, le goût du
combat.
Il faut faire du journalisme de combat.
Oui, il faut
il faut faire du journalisme de combat.
Pourquoi je découragerai pas les gens,
même dans la situation actuelle d'être
journaliste ?
Et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
s'endurcir au combat ?
Traverser l'épreuve du feu
euh
pour s'endurcir au combat. Vous savez là
pour le coup, il y a quand même des
natures, des natures plus ou moins aptes
au combat. Il y a des gens
on peut même pas leur en vouloir qui
sont qui sont pas aptes à tenir les
positions.
C'est comme ça.
Auelin. Merci.
Merci à vous.
Coup.
[Musique]